[Music]
the egyptian pyramids are
a monument to human engineering
preserving both
culture and mummies across millennia
but for the purposes of our microcosmic
journey what's most remarkable about
them
are the bits of fossils that made up
their limestone
as far back as the 5th century bce
the greek historian herodotus noticed
these
shells embedded in the pyramids
what he did not know is that these
shells were the remnants of creatures
that are just as intriguing as the
pyramids
own inhabitants in the early 19th
century
far removed from those pyramids a young
boy named alcide durbini
would become fascinated with the tiny
shells he found on the beach
and when he grew up and expanded his
hobby into a more professional study
he named them and the organisms they
came from he called them
foraminifera
[Music]
if you judge them just from appearances
it might be a surprise to learn that
foraminifera
is an amoeboid protist meaning that
inside that hard
shell which is also called a test there
is a squishy
amoeba while we don't know too much
about how foraminifera evolved from
other eukaryotes we know that they've
been around for over
500 million years and over that time
they've evolved at least 10 000
species that are still living today and
another 40
000 species that we know only through
their fossils
there are two different main types of
foraminifera
most of the living species we know are
benthic foraminifera which means they're
found throughout the ocean's depths
living on rocks and seaweed or just the
ocean floor
they've even been found in abundance in
the challenger deep the deepest known
point in the ocean
the second group are the planktonic
foraminifera which
float on or near the surface of the
ocean thanks in part
to their tests both types of
foraminifera make
and inhabit tests and scientists can use
the materials and test morphology
to distinguish between different species
some foraminifera secrete
compounds like calcium carbonate while
others glue bits of inorganic particles
together with the organic equivalent of
cement and inside the tests are divided
into
chambers with some species creating
complex structures out of these chambers
the way we might
create complex arrangements of rooms in
a building
foraminifera are architects and as they
grow
they build more chambers to accommodate
themselves
some grow so fast they have to add a
chamber
every day the shapes of these chambers
play a particularly crucial role for
planktonic foraminifera
which generally build less complex
structures compared to their benthic
counterparts
the chambers they build are more
globular which provides the planktonic
foraminifera
with a means to stay buoyant as they
float around
but for a minifira or four amps as they
call them in the biz
don't just build shells they also build
webs or more accurately they become
webs the foraminifera tests are lined
with holes that act like little windows
to allow the organism's pseudopodia or
false feet
to peek out peaking might be an
understatement the pseudopodia
reach and reach out forming their own
webs as they do to find
food and catch it these forms of
pseudopodia
are called reticulopodia you can see
here
just how weird and extensive they are
in action they may look like a
disintegrated spider's web but remember
that this
is the organism reaching its own body
out to the microcosms
spreading itself thin as it contorts
into new shapes
zoom in on those reticular podium and
you can see the cytoplasm streaming
through it
like a biological highway
when forearms die the soft matter that
makes up those pseudopodia will
eventually decay but what remains
are the tests and over the hundreds of
millions of years they've existed
the death of foraminifera has become
integrated
into our planet's geology
large swaths of the ocean floor are
covered in the collected remains of
planktonic foraminifera
creating a dense substance called
globigerina ooze
and we owe famous sites like the pink
tinted beaches of bermuda
and the numulitic limestone of the
pyramids to
ancient foraminifera and the abundance
of these fossilized remains provides us
with a record
of our planet's history while forams may
be found throughout our oceans
individual species have their own
environmental needs whether that means
they prefer a particular temperature
or salinity or light condition so
assessing the fossil composition of
different sediments
helps scientists understand what our
world once
looked like and understanding the past
shapes our present as well
with oil companies using microfossils to
understand the geology of the area
they're working in
so where did our fossils come from well
they had a bit of a journey james our
master of microscopes got these samples
from virginia by way of his fiancee
who collected water and sand from the
coast and packed them in a jar
if that seems like an easy enough way to
give the lovely gift of microbes to a
microscopist
just remember that she had to take the
samples from virginia
to poland and that's where things
started to go wrong
first the jar of sand and water leaked
all over her luggage
then after she arrived james's cat
tipped over the jar
as cats do like to do but we cannot
blame the cat
for all the subsequent damage either
because james also tipped the jar over
while trying to open a window
on the one hand the story seems like
something of a cautionary tale on the
importance of
careful jar handling but even after
having lost all that water the jar
was still full of sand and also what
turned out to be a whole
bunch of foraminifera fossils and maybe
that's the true lesson to take from our
shelled amoeboid friends
that even when the world around them has
tipped
and turned and leaked even then
you can find something dazzling in what
remains
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you to
everyone who has so far backed our
kickstarter project
of the micro cosmos microscope we've
blown past our goal and i'm very excited
that we'll be sharing these with you
i've really been enjoying mine i need to
make my
technique better because i've actually
hurt my neck a little bit looking into
it so much
thank you also of course to all of our
patrons on patreon
these people whose names are on the
screen right now
these folks are the reason we are able
to make journey to the micro cosmos
every one of you thank you so much for
giving us this opportunity
to make stuff for you and for everyone
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby